well I take full responsibility for
employing andy coulson I did so on the
basis of undertakings I was given by him
about phone hacking and those turn out
not to be the case I always said that if
they turned out to be wrong I would make
a full and frank apology and I do that
today I'm extremely sorry that I
employed him it was the wrong decision
and I'm very clear about that What did
he say and what did you ask him exactly
about phone hacking and his knowledge of
it we covered all this in the leveson
inquiry I asked him questions about if
he knew about phone hacking and he said
that he didn't and I accepted those
insurances and I gave him the job i
would say that no one has made any
complaints about the work that he did
for me either as leader of the
Opposition or indeed here in number ten
Downing Street but knowing what I now
know and knowing that those assurances
weren't right it was obviously wrong to
employ him I gave someone a second
chance it turned out to be a bad
decision